[Musique]
alors ça je pense que c'est soit une
jambe avec un talon soit coûteux suisse
[Musique]
a tout de suite ça c'est un bon dos
qu'on met le soir de la saint-valentin
et qu'on a sorti à une nuisette qui est
en dessous noir pour être de la même
couleur vrai ou faux un couteau suisse
ça c'est un couteau suisse mais si c'est
un canif je dis ça c'est un truc qu'on
met dans les cheveux quand on a une
coiffure comme ça et consorts par grand
vent pour qu'ils tiennent
ça s'appelle une barrette italienne
parvis mais c'est ça je te dis je vois
un couteau suisse est plein de petits
bouts critique tuk tuk tuk ongles
[Musique]
ah non c'est un coupe ongle sa coupe
ongles ah là là mais c'est pas mon
univers c'est un état chronique aux
banques je peux pas dire des trucs comme
ça
[Musique]